man I was holding a one-and-a-half volt
battery one of those batteries that you
put into a camera on the teeny ones and
I ran 400 miles of wire from this
battery down to Los Angeles this shark
could sense the electrical field off of
that battery 400 miles away so this
sense is five million times more
sensitive than any human sense and is by
far the most sensitive sense we've ever
discovered on the planet
so next time you're swimming at the
dolphin club you can um remember that
sharks aren't really smelling you there
honing in on your electro receptive
field that is coming off of your heart
and brain waves so it was a pretty
frightening thought when I learned that
because I surf down at Ocean Beach all
the time so anyway sharks do it bees do
it birds do it we probably do it too
humans have probably using have been
using some sort of magnetic cept of
cents for centuries ancient Polynesian
sailors could navigate hundreds of miles
across the open ocean and usually always
make it back to the same exact spot now
they could use celestial navigation for
some of the time solar navigation for
some of that other time but they
couldn't use both all of the time
especially during stormy weather so how
did they do it then there's these guys
the goo-goo ammeter and Australian
Aboriginal tribe they incorporated
cardinal directions into their language
they didn't have words for right left
forward or backwards but they did have
words for north south east and west if
one of these guys wanted you to make
room for him on a bench he wouldn't ask
you to move over to the right he would
ask you to move south they didn't bend
backwards
they met eastwards or northwards so the
only way this group could communicate
was if they knew their exact position on
the globe at all times which is a very
hard thing to do at night and a very
hard thing to do and in in close space
but they weren't alone dozens and dozens
of cultures also used cardinal languages
just like these guys
to check shell of central Mexico they
again didn't have words for right or
left but they had words for north south
east and west in the 1990s a bunch of
researchers took one of these shell
speakers and placed him in a room they
blindfolded him and they spun him around
about 25 times and immediately asked him
to identify where north south east and
west was this guy did it without any
hesitation twenty times in a row and I
think they just gave up and moved on
after that so you know thank God for the
70s here's a here's a picture from some
70s experiments in the 70s and 80s human
magnetic reception was all the rage they
conducted over 1,000 experiments in this
stuff and almost all the time people who
were blindfolded twisted around magnets
on their head whatever they were able to
point in their home direction with one
exception when the experimenters would
tape a little piece of magnetite to
their foreheads they lost all sense of
direction now researchers had done this
years before they had taken a turtle and
they had taken a bird and taped I'm not
talking about a kitchen magnet I'm
talking about a teeny teeny piece and
it's really sad if you ever see these
videos because turtles just kind of swim
in circles lazily they have no idea how
to make their way around so something
was interesting I saw a couple days ago
that the Nobel Prize in science just
went to some researchers that identified
something called the internal GPS within
cells this these cells are able to
activate and stay activated only when an
animal is facing in one particular
direction which is how we're able to
find our way around and remember where
we've gone we don't know if these cells
are banged narrow receptive yet but it
makes sense that they would be they're
doing more research in that so I know
what you're thinking is like it seems
impossible that we would have the sense
when we can't find our way out of a
shopping mall or a parking lot the fact
is we just don't need it today too much
but we did need it about four hundred
years ago and before then the
is what Manhattan was supposed to look
like about 400 years ago you'd need a
pretty good sense of direction to make
it through here and especially through
the heavily forested areas this is what
Manhattan looks like now you need zero
sense of direction to make it around
here the pattern of settlement roads and
other landmarks that under grid our
modern society make it easy to know
exactly where we are
and of course ever we're in doubt you
pull out your phone and from practically
anywhere on the planet you can see
exactly where you are through GPS
[Music]
you